Congress is sounding the alarm on the
World Health Organization's failed kovat
19 response and it's troubling ties to
China the agency's embattled director is
coming under major fire facing new
pressure from lawmakers to testify
before Congress and explain his
relationship with the communist regime
the w-h-o has repeatedly praised China's
transparency despite Beijing's attempt
to cover up the crisis here's President
Trump on his threat to cut the funding
over the years many years we've been
paying them from 300 to 500 and even
more million dollars a year China has
been paying them less than 40 and they
are very very china centric as I said
during the week China centric China
always seems the bet to get the better
of the the argument and I don't like
that we're gonna be talking about that
next week in great detail we're looking
at it very very closely
so Dana one of the things I found out
was the relationship between China and
Ethiopia the country where dr. Ted Rose
the chair of the w-h-o came from China
groomed this guy and China has been
grooming Ethiopia almost like a colonial
power dynamic for many many years
billion-dollar trade billion-dollar
investments in infrastructure and all
sorts of deals and they really wined and
dined this guy he was their top pick
America didn't want this guy he was
China's top pick they got him and it
paid off so you're about to hear the
train by the way just so you know it's
not so here you can you can actually go
around the world right now because of
China's aggressive investment into this
belton Road initiative you can find
people from all over the world who are
basically in China's back pocket now dr.
Ted Rose had been praised in the past by
somebody like dr. pouchy
so they've known each other for years
maybe there is not a lot to see here but
it is suspicious and especially because
you look back to those cholera epidemics
that we took that you mentioned the
other day Jesse that happened in each
yo piya and there are questions about
that and a friend of mine who's former
intelligence told me that he's super
suspicious of all of this I think that
the president is a little bit like the
boss who calls you on a Friday and says
make sure you come to my office at 10
a.m. Monday I have something really
important for you to talk about and then
you worry about it all weekend because
what the president did right before the
clip that you showed is he said we're
thinking about this and next week we're
gonna make an announcement and next week
we're gonna talk about what we're going
to do with the funding for the w-h-o and
you just know that it's going to ruin
their weekend and they're gonna be
worried about it all week here's one
thing I would recommend I think that you
look at a global pandemic and you
realize it's super important to have
something like the World Health
Organization so that we're all
communicating with each other stamping
things out as soon as they get involved
but we can't just be involved with the
money we have to have a much more heavy
hand involvement with Western societies
and the United States so I wouldn't
necessarily cut back the funding I would
push ahead and make sure the United
States has more influence 1 what would
you do or if you were in charge because
the w-h-o was saying things it just
weren't scientific they were saying
masks don't work travel bans don't work
this thing's not contagious I mean
they're the World Health Organization
what do you do well I mean I think first
of all you don't want to politicize a
pandemic and I think w-h-o plays an
important role as we're trying to get a
you know international cooperation in
dealing with this we can't stop at one
corner and pretend you know oh it's over
because if you have it all over the
world Jesse you got to deal with it all
over the world and that's why you need a
World Health Organization I do think
that China told lies and I think they in
some cases lied to the w-h-o and the
w-h-o then echoed those lies so do I
blame the w-h-o to some extent yes but
most of all I blame China and when you
think about the w-h-o and the role that
it's performed you know I think things
like the use of masks even our experts
here in the US have changed their
position on it but the w-h-o said very
clearly when they
cleared there was a global pandemic we
you know in this country our president
was saying we can handle this we got
this under control so you see I mean
there's all kinds of finger-pointing and
blame games as I've said to you on other
topics I'm not sure this is helpful as
we try to come to terms with things in
the political arena though I think that
you have people who want to point
fingers and blame the w-h-o I think they
should maybe you know what go after
China if you want to China
fortunately hubs so much of our debt and
control some of our manufacturing take a
look at your iPhone so it's hard to go
after China may be easier to pick on the
w-h-o but this is not the right time to
do it right I mean I believe both are
culpable but I would agree that China's
more culpable and Lindsey Graham agrees
let's play Lindsey and then you can
react mister gutfeld the first thing I
want to do is get the United States
Senate on the record where we we don't
blame Trump we blame China the Chinese
government is responsible for 16,000
American deaths and 17 million Americans
being unemployed is the Chinese
government and the way they behave it
led to this pandemic well you know I'm
not interested that much in the in the
blame component I'm interested in the
relationship between China and the World
Health Organization and then how we can
modify it so it serves our needs we know
that essentially China is like a big
business and the World Health
Organization is their press office and
so they're the Public Relation flacks
who smooth over the oil spill right or
the accidental food poisoning or the
escaped virus right there are those
catastrophic public relations agencies
that are working on behalf of China now
we have no reason to doubt what they
were doing because hey it's the World
Health Organization anything with world
as a prefix has to be good right world
music can't stand it anyway so the
solution for me and I'm again it has
nothing to do with picking on them it's
a construct constructive solution is to
take all the involuntary funding I think
there's I don't know how much it is I
know there's voluntary funding from
private people but take the other
give it to the people that are suffering
the small business so because the people
are being harmed by China and by
relationship who you know you could sue
China or you just take that money and
funnel it to America's bar tab because
that's what this is about we need to pay
America's bar tab when people come back
so that they spend more money that
doesn't assign any blame it just shifts
a sum of money over to the victims who
could really use it that's my solution
Emily do you like the idea of WH o
picking up our bar tab do you have
anyone picking up our bar tab I think
that's great I think the question that
is that president Trump and the other
world leaders are facing right now is
how do we compel China ever to play by
the same rules as everybody else you
know this is only one example of like 50
concurrent elements right now where
they're history of subversion and a lack
of transparency has resulted in global
negative results and given their current
issues with Environment and trade and
Wildlife it's not as if this might not
happen in the future again and so I
think moving forward there needs to be
some type of global consensus where
there's a zero tolerance for them so at
least now there's sort of a conversation
about it yeah well apparently last night
Peter Navarro
on Martha's show said that the United
Nations have about 15 different little
sub agencies like the w-h-o and China
controls five out of the 15 so we have
to figure a way to wrestle those away
all right coming up